[Musique]
certains enfants ne savaient pas ce qu'est
un bâtiment, ce qu'est une maison
parce qu'ils ont toujours été dans une tente, donc
nous devions leur expliquer qu'est-ce que c'est, qu'est-
ce qu'une maison,
vous savez, ils ne connaissent pas  un lit, euh, tu
sais,
peut-être des chaises, des
tables, une cuisine ou autre,
donc il y a tellement de choses
qu'ils ont besoin d'apprendre
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
certaines des femmes qui se sont
échappées du camp sont venues d'elles-mêmes
à travers la Turquie,
euh et puis le  le ministère
les aiderait de la Turquie
à la Finlande, puis ils nous informeraient
que d'accord, maintenant ils sont ici
et aussi que nous avons fait
apprendre aux enfants
à lire
et à leur apprendre une nouvelle langue
très facilement, je pense que c'est gentil  d'entre vous
savent que cela m'a ouvert les yeux parce que nous avons
vraiment besoin
d'éducation,
par exemple dans les
zones rurales, en Afrique, en Asie ou en
Amérique latine, etc. et c'est
quelque chose dans lequel je voudrais vraiment
m'impliquer d'une manière ou d'une autre.